how's it going my name is Bella man and
welcome back to some more cyan blood
curse I am a little girl look at me you
should I don't even know I actually have
no idea what you should do I didn't even
know how you got there little girl but
we have to escape and there's blood on
the walls so that's just fantastic all
right
hello Oh No
let's go over here or not
[ __ ] I don't even know Crouch crouch
mode activate oh god she's right there
it's okay it's not too processed no
problema what is it
excuse me you have a wonderful laugh
lady wonderful I love it okay whoa whoa
whoa whoa hello I don't even I don't
like this okay
use the circuits see to go to the
bathing you how do I get my map I forgot
all right here we go
staircase see it's pretty much far away
all right not too whoa well that's a
problem just kidding - what am I suppose
it's a penis and it's a huge whoa whoa
whoa all right let's go let's go ah yes
Mon little higher
Oh No did you see me all right but I
don't even care it's going here what the
[ __ ] am I
please tell me this is that Casey hello
I'm a little girl don't rape me please
you said I did it all right awesome you
second lady head up to the first floor
no oh no oh I don't even know why I'm
praying for his butters and mode I don't
even all right god damn it they're
everywhere whoa
I would vibrate I have a dildo in my
pockets no I'm for it's impossible
well what is that what the hell
oh no oh now rolling hill heads it
sounds like a band got a flower
got a flower I don't like this
second a where I yeah forward to why did
not a problem not a problem not a
problem not a problem not a problem not
a problem not a problem
I actually prefer that first person
there thank you kind of nice call for
help from the reception done they
started oh it's right here I oh no it's
locked
incinerator I don't want to go to an
incinerator I'm pretty sure I don't want
that i whatever this is a bathroom you
could keep an incinerator in your
bathroom I'm just saying alright where
is it incinerator where are you is it on
another floor perhaps Bella
sounds like the Twilight girl I love
that girl no I don't I'm just kidding
why would anyone I'm not a girl I mean
Edward did that just not Edwards fault
his vampire all right maybe it's
upstairs I'm just guessing here alright
then now we check the map and if it's
here I will be happy and goddammit
all right let's try cuz I don't even
know
please be here why would you keep an
incinerator on the top floor
use your brain pity alright I'm using my
brain it's not a flower I don't get it
no I don't think that was a flower sub
mountain girl all right there
incinerator is probably in the basement
if you think really hard super high like
your nipples
everyone's nipples wants to be hard like
an incinerator ah there we go
Tanya whoa hello let's not go there dad
was the sound of your genitals no listen
what am I wait a second am I going back
way today oh it's right there all right
all right cool Tech gone you two and
lady
wait it was they aside
I was right there pick it up
hello I am si on you girl alright
progress and a kibosh feels like I'm if
I'm crouching and watching the stars
it's like I'm out whatever we need to go
in here let's do it
I didn't even know why we're going again
oh we're calling for help on the radio
all right let's call for momma and Poppa
[Music]
that's not a good idea I don't think I
have it it's working
howdy chef and what do you know oh no oh
hell naw Oh No whoa what the hell where
did he go
all right escape the staircase in the
basement
strike the Shibata but something in the
kitchen
[ __ ] sub-goals
alright let's go in the basement let's
go
March debate are we in the basement
escape using the employer side case all
right we need to go oh no back up back
all right
No
I'll zoom don't why did you stir it
around like that
I haven't escaped from Sol right I will
do it
wait a second okay again I thought it's
a [ __ ] everything all right let's go
to the basement turn off our flashlights
crouching mode activate I don't know how
I activate the goddamnit
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa no no
no no all right we're good
we are freaky freaky new freak around a
hooker hooker all right here we go you
can do it payday
you can do this little girl I'm not
afraid you are not if you're not afraid
I'm sure as hell not afraid all right we
need to go through the kitchen no we
have to go through there I don't
I don't even know I think rather
I think we have to go to the kitchen
distract her and then somehow get passed
through or something oh you can go
through here what am i sponsored ow I'm
so screwed
[ __ ] man sup let's just take it sweet
baby left
not like a boss ground like a bar like
mother like a bus boy why are you doing
this run like a boss you're a boss girl
squeeze through like a [ __ ] oh thank
god okay oh I don't what are you doing
ah no I wanted that back
it had [ __ ] ponies on it a god damn
it
mission accom I did it this game is
difficult
Holly [ __ ] alright alright let's play a
little more cuz why the eff not
I feel like this channel has been
missing us seriously
I don't know I want to have one game
running at least so regardless if
everyone loves this or not I will
probably play it cuz I think it's funny
and she was stabbed that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] V in the back hall he's raping
your mom Bella you better do something
oh no she's infected now I told you why
she holding the flash back there
oh hell she's in trouble
they really switch character a lot here
but it's okay nice legs he's like I'm
gonna tap that all on the floor tap that
give me some more EEMA girl you okay
why is he looking at it are you okay
I have done that far too many times yes
that's right he wants to stare at her
titties he has Kurds nipples
yes that should do it
smack him with a stick
oh my god he's pissing that's a good
resistance to get him
she does have a stick though I would be
careful if I was in don't tell me she's
gonna come with me can't I choose to
kill her or something I don't want a
girl that putz max goddamnit
alright puppy girl I need some rules
hey don't copy me hey that's a pleasure
don't copy me I got my swag going I
don't need your [ __ ] reach the
Westfield's that's these fields where's
the West there it is alright we have to
go left
that's a problem now what are you doing
not get our fair barrel stupid [ __ ] can
I climb these yes I can what the hell is
that
all right I don't want to know actually
let's keep climbing
Oh No what did I do
oh god what I don't kill the girl she
only has a stick
Oh God is your I know it's bad idea
picking her with me find a different way
god damn it alright when word [ __ ] oh no
that's okay if it's okay it's okay don't
hahaha her face that's my face usually
what's she doing come she's gonna die
you know I can't protect her stupid vows
thought yeah [ __ ] bad alright she's
running is she running we better run too
all right we made it good girl
I guess we got to go through here the
map doesn't line up very well with the
gameplay but that's okay
is she with me or what are you with me
girl I guess not well I don't care well
I'll come on let's go in here
[Music]
well she scared me don't touch my girl
bitch-slap all on the floor bitch-slap
give me some mud [ __ ]
well you mess me oh no no no don't just
stare there please
ah [ __ ] there's more of them I got damn
it all right I'm over here hey you're
done
hey you're done no right babe I don't
get this at all all right whatever
whatever let's go let's go everything
all right that's perfect
place a tender never all right that's it
for today like and favorite should
enjoyed subscribe if you become a brush
today and I'll see you next episode
that's pretty much it take me writin
[Music]
yeah I make you penetrated made I like
it
I don't yeah oh sorry